-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated actor
you know from his work on shows
such as "Justified," "Deadwood,"
and "Santa Clarita Diet."
You can see him next
in "Amsterdam,"
which premieres in theaters
October 7th.
Let's take a look.
-Then I saw the man,
this red-faced man,
the man who pushed Liz Meekins.
And he looked right at me
and he said...
-This is your moment
to end your inferiority.
You can have that procedure.
♪♪
-Don't move!
-[ Grunting ]
[ Gun clicks ]
-[Bleep]
[ Gunshot ]
-[ Grunting ]
-Come on.
-Stop those people.
-Please welcome back to the show
my very good friend
Timothy Olyphant!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Please sit down.
-I want -- I feel --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Huh?
-I want you -- I want you
to admit to them
what you just told me.
-No, no, this is your show.
That's your job.
Let me tell you something --
-Alright, well, can I tell them
what you just told me?
-Please, go for it.
-You -- We shook hands.
I said, "Thanks for being here."
And then you --
you wouldn't let go.
-Uh-huh.
-And you said, "I told my wife
I'm gonna hold this hug
for an uncomfortably long time."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
And then she said --
I said, "Because the audience
likes that.
They -- They think we're
talking about something."
-Yeah.
-And she said -- And she said,
"Tim, you're trying too hard."
[ Laughter ]
-You told me that whole exchange
while we were over there, yeah.
-That's -- That's what happened.
-This is very nice --
-And I gotta say.
-What?
-I think I was trying too hard.
-You do?
-Yeah, yeah.
No, I think she's right.
I think I was trying too hard.
You guys are going for it
right now.
But I also think she was right.
-You know what?
I like that you held me
for a really long time
and then you still
made a real meal,
like, making a real long loop.
Did the --
You pointed at the band.
-Honestly, I got a little lost.
Because it's been a while.
-It has been a while.
-It's been a long time since --
since I've seen you.
It's lovely to see you,
by the way.
And lovely to see all of you
and the band.
I appreciate the band.
I see Syd there.
What?
-All of your --
All of your appearances
on this show were memorable,
but we had
a very memorable Zoom.
Uh, and sort of
sartorially memorable
because of what
you were wearing.
Uh, a very charming hat,
and then the whole interview
I'm like,
"Is that a Van Halen jersey?"
What is that?
-Yeah, no, I picked it up
at one of the shows.
That's a Van Halen jersey.
-Okay, so you went
to a Van Halen show,
and you bought -- that's merch?
-Yeah.
Which is big for me
that I bought something.
'Cause I'm pretty -- I'm into
the -- I'm in show business.
-Yeah.
-I like the free stuff.
But -- But I paid for that
at a Van Halen show.
It was a good show,
and Eddie had passed away,
perhaps that day.
-Rest in peace, yeah.
-And so I broke out the shirt.
It was the day -- It was
in honor of Eddie Van Halen.
-You know, there's
another interesting thing
about show business,
where some people will --
you know,
they'll get a stylist,
and they'll wear
a piece of clothing once.
-Yeah, it's been
recommended to me.
[ Laughter ]
-But we noticed something
about your hat.
You just had the premiere
for your film "Amsterdam,"
and, uh, I think
you double dipped.
-Yeah.
-So the hat --
-The hat's back.
-Yeah.
I was terribly underdressed.
I have to admit.
-No, don't -- don't say
you're terribly underdressed.
Here's Drake at the same thing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He might have overdid it,
but --
It doesn't appear
as though the invitation
just said "dress code."
It said, "Your call."
-Yeah.
-Whatever you want.
Because, yeah, I -- yeah.
-It does feel like
you just realized
what your cast members
are wearing,
and you look like you're about
to, like, make a break for it.
You have -- You have the gait
of a man who's about to leave.
-I will say, before I forget,
because I often do forget
to say this,
it was just a genuine pleasure
to be part of that film.
-Yeah, and a wonderful cast.
-It meant a great deal
to be part of that film.
And every step along the way
has just been --
-And they tried real hard
in the clip --
they tried real hard
to give you ugly face.
Still can't do it.
-It was clear --
It did occur to me
when I showed up on set
and I'd gone through
hair and makeup
that he clearly had somebody
else in mind for the part.
[ Laughter ]
But -- 'Cause I said to him --
It's a David O. Russell film,
one of my favorite filmmakers
of all time.
And at one point,
I do remember saying to him,
"You know, you probably
could have just hired someone
who looked like this."
[ Laughter ]
"I mean,
I'm thrilled to be here.
I'm glad you didn't."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-It was really
quite a thrilling experience.
-Do you --
We've talked about your kids.
You've got three --
two girls and a boy.
Do they give you feedback when
you show up in public like this?
Or is that -- is that a thing
where you don't hear much?
-Uh, well, I -- They weren't --
I didn't bring this up.
So my --
They don't give a [bleep]
-They don't give a [bleep]
-Yeah.
-But you -- I should note, one
of your co-stars, Taylor Swift.
-Yeah.
-Did they --
-No.
-That matters, right?
-Yeah.
Yeah, my kids have gotten --
They get very excited
about people in the --
Music business people,
they get very excited.
Taylor they were
very excited about.
Yeah, and I'm aware of it,
so I'll tell them,
"Yeah, I'm working
with Taylor Swift today."
Because, you know,
you try to get a little --
-A little currency
with the kids?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Listen, you're gonna --
you're gonna --
You don't know this yet, but
you're gonna get to this place,
and it feels like desperation,
where you're like --
You catch yourself saying, like,
"I'm working
with Taylor Swift today."
And as soon as you say it,
you're like,
"What the [bleep]
is wrong with me?
Why am I trying to impress
my own goddamn children?"
They're my --
You know what I mean?
-And they can smell it on you,
right?
-Oh, my God, they can smell it.
But I know they're --
That is the only thing.
You know, I was at --
The greatest thing
that ever happened to me,
as far as my children
are concerned.
We were at the "Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood" --
What was that film called?
-Yeah, yeah.
The Quentin Tarantino film?
-"Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood."
-Yeah.
DiCaprio, Brad Pitt.
-Exactly.
So, we're at that premiere.
And my kids, for the most part,
we never took them
to any of these things.
But now they're older.
They're out of the house.
We miss 'em.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's so nice.
So nice.
We miss 'em, but, oh, my God.
Anyway, we take 'em
to the premiere,
and that's when it --
Brad Pitt and then Leo,
and it was all very exciting,
but when they saw Snoop Dogg...
-Really?
-Oh, my God.
-That was the one?
-Like, they were like,
"Oh, my God, it's --"
They went crazy.
They were so excited.
And we were with someone
who knew him,
and said, "Do you want
to come meet him?"
And they were like,
"Of course we do.
Of course we do."
They were so excited.
And it was the greatest thing
that ever could happen to me
in front of my kids.
When I was first -- I was the
first to be introduced to him,
and he looked at me.
You know, someone said,
"Snoop, Tim. Tim, Snoop."
And he looked at me and goes,
"You're a bad mother[bleep]"
[ Laughter ]
-That's the best.
That's the best.
I mean...
-I tried so hard --
You don't understand
what it took for me
to stay focused and cool...
-Yeah.
-...in that moment and not
look at my children and go...
[ Laughter ]
Like, the most uncool thing.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So you just had to take it.
-I literally almost looked
at them and said, "See!"
[ Laughter ]
"Do you not see?"
-Alright, well,
you gotta stick around,
'cause I have a lot more
questions about your kids.
We'll be right back.